business all right this is business man
this ain't oh what your dreams is I
would like to have a character thrown in
a world and you can have this as a match
and the boss is an actual character bro
that sounds nice but they not doing that
nobody's taking we're in an economic
downturn it's not like this Fortnight
level some stuff is Gonna Get You Know
thrown to the Wayside as much as
Titanfall was this dope game yeah first
one was dope second one was even better
it didn't get the reach wow and a dope
game will get reached right if it's so
dope how come nobody heard it okay
let me let me push back on that yeah why
is the anime why did the anime makers of
my hero put my hero in fortnite King
is the anime not dope